bismillah alhamdulillah I said I'm all
alaikum peace be unto you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show he's back again
dr. Bilal Philips to help clear that way
there's some confusion out there there
are many ways calling people saying that
they're the correct way so how does one
differentiate the true way of life the
true religion the true way to be
successful from all these thousands
hundreds of ways saying that they're the
way so when he comes out we're going to
try to answer this very crucial question
here on the Deen show you don't want to
go nowhere we'll be right back
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
is just to break the ice
so our Lake oh I come sit down doctor ah
back again on the Dean show my pleasure
to be back alright thank you very much
my pleasure people can read about you at
the Dean show calm you have your own
private section is that right that's
right
how's your picture there and they click
on the picture and your bio is there and
the show that we did purpose of life
that's the crucial question but another
question is people are like you know
what religions are all the same they're
man-made I'll just do my own thing how
does one differentiate the true way of
life if one has already acknowledged
which sin is very nature that there's a
crater but now you have all these
different isms these different ways how
do you differentiate what is the true
way the true way to success happiness
peace and the pleasure of the creator of
the heavens on earth talk to us please
well if we're to find the true way we
have to believe of course that this true
way must have come from God so if it's
coming from God it must have what we
call a scriptural basis there should be
a scripture there and then that
scripture should be one in which there
is no doubt no doubt no doubt about the
authenticity of its text its origin the
protection of that text from any change
or modification so that we know what is
in our hands was what was revealed then
we know we have a religion whose basis
was foundation is solid otherwise if the
document that is claimed to be the
origin is something which they've got so
many different manuscripts of and no two
manuscripts agree with each other like
the Gospels for example here over 5,000
manuscripts no two manuscripts are
grieving all details with each other
and at present we have something like
5500 manuscripts in Greek of the New
Testament which is a lot for an ancient
book it's far more than any other
ancient book the problem is most of
these copies are hundreds and hundreds
of years after the originals and all of
them have differences in them so that
the scribes who are copying these
manuscripts changed the text that they
were copying sometimes by accident
sometimes they just made mistakes they
were sleepy or incompetent or whatever
but sometimes it looks like scribes
actually thought the text should say
something other than it did and then
they so they would change the text so
then which one's right how do you figure
it out yeah you know are the Gita or the
you know scriptures of the Hindus and
others you know when they were written
they have no idea bits and pieces here
and there you know it's of uncertain
origin who wrote they don't know clouded
clouded in confusion and uncertainty
yeah so when you have texts like that I
mean even the Old Testament which may be
a little more accurate and more solid
than the New Testament writings but even
that the scholars scriptural crypts
criticism are shown contradictions that
exist in it
some places it looks like it's a
manipulation of the text where where the
author wants to change where the scribe
wants to change what the author said I
mean in many cases it may be that the
scribe thought this is what the author
really meant and so he changed it but
but sometimes the the text gets changed
to say just the opposite of what it
originally said and so that's that came
back to me a little bit troubling yeah
different documents should be new
stories which are being repeated and in
different ways and all kinds of doubts
there yeah that doubts so we can
distinguish with you we just have to put
the basic scriptures on the table and
say like which one we can be 100% sure
about and that's the quicker the
evidence is there speaks for itself so
it can that is external yeah that's what
an external perspective yeah then
internally what does that text contain
no is that text if it's from God it
should contain accurate information
it shouldn't have fallacies and you know
contradictions with modern science and
these kinds of things when you pick up
the other text you read in there maybe
you might find some interesting things
here and there but there's a lot of old
wives tales which don't agree with what
we know about science today yeah when
you go in the Quran you go from chapter
to chapter and you look at scientific
things which was talked about in the
Quran they match modern scientific
theory so much so that when the verses
were shown to dr. Keith Moore who
written wrote the book on embryology
yeah right the book used in all of the
medical colleges around the world they
showed him these verses from the Quran
which described the development of the
fetus at the time when it's not visible
to the naked eye
he said Muhammad could not have known
these facts about human development in
the seventh century because most of them
were not discovered until the 20th
century that God transmitted through
Mohammed bits of his knowledge that we
have only discovered for ourselves in
recent times 1400 years ago when the
world was immersed in darkness the Quran
was revealed which brought light to a
beleaguered world and whereas the
earlier books came with many scientific
mistakes due to the hand of man having
delved into them the Quran had none of
these contradictions the world thought
there could be no reconciliation between
religion and science but the Quran
mentioned many scientific facts in great
detail like how a human being developed
in the mother's womb and described other
scientific facts which amazed the
world's renowned scientists and
scientific community this could not have
come from Muhammad so they said then
where did it come from
it must have come from God no doubt not
possible to describe what is there when
the microscope wasn't developed until
many centuries after him
yeah this is the evidence these are
concrete bits and pieces of evidence
that internal you have external you
haven't oh and then the overall message
which is being taught I mean it's not a
whole bunch of fairy tales wild
fantastic tales but things which seem to
match the realities of this life you
read the Quran this is God talking to
you directly so now so a person doesn't
have to go deep into let's say Buddhism
Christianity or any kind of Hindu
religion or all Sikhism now at the face
of it so they're looking for
contradictions mistakes things that are
rational what are they actually looking
for these are some of the things that
you mentioned that it has to be the
message has to be lucid clear something
that is basically not flawed by man and
then if it is leave it along go to the
next there's an islamic courage that you
look at these different ways and you'll
come to realization if you're sincere
and you're asking the crater to guide
you that you eventually end up back to
this way the way of all the prophets
islam
if a person is sincere god is going to
guide them yeah that's for sure if
they're sincere but they have to be
ready to act then on the knowledge that
they get from this problem is that a lot
of people may come and realize yes the
truth is there with Islam yeah but to
take that on what is involved in
becoming a Muslim creates such problems
and families you know how parents are
going to react are the wife and the kids
and you know and the husband and the the
kids how are they gonna react how am I
gonna deal with all this some people say
hey too much that's the really feel I
like what you have yeah it makes sense
it's very good I'm just not ready to
deal with the consequences and that's
sad because one cannot afford once you
seek the truth in Oz's mentioned in the
Bible the truth is going to set you free
that's true set you free from ignorance
bring you to the realization of the true
God so once you're there
for you to turn aside and say well
because of people I can't deal with this
that's a big mistake that is the most
serious possible mistake that you can
make in your life to have known the
truth in its clarity with certainty and
turned away what can we see after that
yeah so does it seem like these other
religions ways are just things because
the inside of the person is searching
yearning for something so this is
convenient now the other religions you
can just modify them to your way it can
just you can put it in and it doesn't
have to inconvenience you or something
but it's not easy yeah
it doesn't require that much commitment
you know you can do it once a week or
you know when you feel like you know
it's good it's it's it's a this a fast
food like a fast food I know so it's not
it's not a real change where to become a
Muslim requires major change it requires
taking on a commitment 24/7 24/7
there's no part-time Muslim I mean of
course the people who might do Islam
part-time but that's not real Islam real
Islam requires 24/7 commitment
there's no time when you take a vacation
from Islam yeah so that Islam that we're
talking about we're talking about that
complete conscious decision that I'm
gonna surrender I'm going to submit I'm
gonna be obedient to the one who created
me and it's a summed up with one word in
Arabic Islam exactly yes mission to the
will of God
some people get hung up now on the
Arabic now they feel that possibly look
this this is an Arab thing this is an
Arabic thing how do we have them look
past this
well reality is that the followers of
the Prophet may God's peace and
blessings be upon him came from all
parts of the world we had them coming
from Persia coming from Abyssinia
coming from all over you know from right
from his generation reality is is that
the vast majority of Muslims
world are not Arabs Arabs only make up a
fraction 15% of the whole of the Muslim
nation
you know 1.5 billion people Arabs are
only a fraction the total number of
Muslims in India alone is more than the
total number of Arabs so it's not an
Arabic religion becomes but okay Arabic
is there but this Arabic is a unifier so
that the nature of our prayer is such
that no matter where you go you can join
in your brothers and sisters with them
in prayer yeah you know I go to China if
you heard the event in Chinese well then
you wouldn't even know what's going on
the call to prayer yeah but when you
hear it's an Arabic you know exactly
where ever you are any Muslim here is
that they know there's a mosque here
you're going there the guys gonna lead
the prayer he's he does it in Chinese
again you're lost what is he doing
what's he saying
he speaks in Arabic everybody can fall
in and it's the unifying factor and
again it is also the language of
Revelation the language in which God
revealed his final message so you learn
Arabic not to be an Arab but to be able
to hear the Word of God as it was
revealed I mean Jesus spoke Aramaic the
gospel that he received was an Aramaic
but there are tribes in in Syria today
that speak Aramaic he didn't speak
English this being English they didn't
speak Latin you know from which they are
Greek from which these things were
translated he spoke Aramaic so where is
his gospel it's lost not known was it
now meant for a particular time of
particular people and now we don't have
it because some people would argue that
world they've got to make a mistake now
because this is supposed to be for all
for all of us until today so now how did
this how do we lose it now to God make a
mistake or wasn't meant to be saved when
there's no there's no mistake here
because the fact that Jesus's message
was for as you said
a particular people in a particular
place for a particular period of time a
prophet was going to come after him who
would bring the final message which
would be for all people in all places at
all times so all of the earlier prophets
the Scriptures were not guarded and
preserved by God as he guarded and
preserved the Quran not because they
were not scripture as they're all
scripture in that sense they're all
equal they're all the Word of God convey
to human beings but the changes that
took place by human hands to the earlier
scriptures God permitted because those
messages were not eternal messages there
were messages for particular people
particular places particular times yes
so the final message if it were to be
the final message it had to be preserved
and that's again evidence of its
truthfulness and finality do we still
have the word of the Creator in what we
have in the Bible today we have bits and
pieces bits and pieces bits and pieces
here and there and these are affirmed in
the Quran where many places which affirm
texts from the Bible but the the
totality of what's there is confusion
for a long time I thought that the Bible
was inspired and inerrant that there
were no mistakes in the Bible but as I
engaged in historical research on the
Bible as I was getting my PhD in New
Testament studies at Princeton
Theological Seminary I started finding
mistakes in the Bible and this this cut
away at my assumptions that the Bible
was inerrant and then I started
questioning other parts of my faith is
Jesus really divine is a really eternity
it's confusion but a person who reads it
sincerely from beginning to end he will
be forced to accept the oneness of God
because that message is there in spite
of all the distortions and all the other
things that are there the oneness of God
is there all of the earlier prophets
talking one
Oh God and Jesus affirming when they
asked him what is the command God's
command he said here o Israel the Lord
your God is one God one God he's
affirming the same thing that came
before so anybody who reads that is ok
where did the Trinity thing come from
yeah it definitely is not in the text
mm-hmm you know this is something people
add it what is the text now which is
clear oneness of God is crystal clear
it's the Quran now if we take what is
meant for a people at that time and
people saying the Son of God because
many people believe that Jesus was God's
Son of God what's a confusion here and
they have to do a bunch of mental
gymnastics to make it fit but now if you
take this what's meant is it that he was
a righteous upright person close to God
but if you take this out and you take it
now to let's say the Greeks who are
worshipping dem I gots meye gods this
guy that guy can can that be where a lot
of the confusion came where now they
take what is meant for that time and is
understood and now you bring it over to
another totally pagan society and
they're already worshipping man guards
and now we have what we have today
modern day man worship Jesus is a son
son of God definitely I mean this is a
one of the explanations of the process
of what took place yeah I mean of course
the message of Jesus was crystal clear
clear it had to be crystal clear because
if it's coming from God that clarity is
gonna be there and it remained clear but
what happened is that when it was taken
out of the way we could say the East and
it came now into the West then these
changes took place whether it was a
question of interpreting or
misinterpreting earlier text or really
introducing ideas which were never in
the original text which I feel it's
probably more of that than actually
misinterpretation
because misinterpretation sort of
implies that the message wasn't that
clear whereas I don't believe that
it's the case in fact the message of
Jesus was very clear in fact after Jesus
left as they thought he was killed or
whatever you know but when Jesus went
away the one who came behind him who
became the head of the Jerusalem church
is none other than James was called in
the gospel the brother of Jesus and
James as the head of the Jerusalem
church taught that Jesus was a prophet
of God God was one he was a Unitarian he
wasn't the Trinitarian so wasn't unto us
for those that period of almost like 70
years after the time of Jesus that was
the main church the Jerusalem church was
a Unitarian Church preaching the message
of the one God and that Jesus was a
human being and a prophet of God was
sent to convey this message but with the
dispersion of the Jews the breakup of
the Temple of Solomon Jews being
dispersed from Jerusalem and of course
the Muslims or we could say the
judeo-christians of that time who were
those who truly follow Jesus externally
they wouldn't look any different from
the regular Jews so when they dispersed
everybody had to disperse so the
Jerusalem church which was the main core
Center from which the teachings the true
teachings of Jesus being taught that was
destroyed and people had to flee so when
that was lost in the center in Antioch
which was headed by Paul right Paul now
took over the movement and he started he
had already been doing it earlier now he
was given a full clear hand
James is assassinated he has the full
clear hand to change the message and
preach the new religion which he called
Christianity which obviously Jesus his
followers they never taught
and ever thought were opposed to took
Paul to task called him to Jerusalem and
questioned him why are you doing this
why are you doing that
that's what's even recorded in the
Gospels to today and the writings the
letters of Paul let's talk about the
uniqueness of this name Islam compared
to what the other religions are named
after well the other religions tend to
be named after people you know the Jews
or they may be named after a particular
person
Buddhists Buddhism from Buddha yeah or
they're named after a place Hinduism
from the Indus Valley you know they're
connected to people's persons places
whereas Islam means submission to the
will of God in the name of the religion
is the central pillar the basic concept
the essence of the religion that's what
it refers to Muslim is not the name of a
person it's the name of one who does
Islam right it is the what they call the
present participle you know one who does
that act of Islam or submission is
called a Muslim so the name of the
religion is found in the text in the
holy text right you cannot find Hinduism
in the Hindu texts you cannot find
Buddhism in the Buddhist texts and I
cannot find Christianity in the
Christians out there that the Jesus call
his followers Christians know this was
Paul is the one who invented that name
so is it safe to say that Jesus peace
before you is alive today
did he ever hear this word Christian if
Moses was alive today did he ever hear
this term to be would he be labeled a
Jew or will he be labeled a Christian or
would he be labeled a Muslim all of the
prophets would have been labeled Muslims
because this essential message was the
same message submission to the will of
God beginning with Adam what was the
command that he was given the command he
was given was to submit to the will of
God
eat from that tree that's what that's
the essence of all that no that was the
essence of the religion you can eat from
all of the other trees quite similar to
the one but this one here don't eat from
it submission will you submit or not and
that's a slap that is Islam that's why
we say Islam is the original religion
one cannot claim Christianity was a
religion of Adam no way can why cannot
Kareem Judaism or Buddhism or any other
of the isms but we can claim maybe you
don't accept it that's another issue we
can claim that Islam was the religion of
Adam and Eve that was the religion which
God revealed to them they were commanded
to submit to the will of God and that is
what Islam means so when when the first
man Adam he disobeyed and he ate from
this tree was
this tree was it beautified for him that
he was lured into this and then at when
he did this was he forgiven afterwards
well the reality as it is recorded in
the Quran is that after Adam and Eve ate
and they sought forgiveness from God
because of course for God to have put
them in a situation like that yeah
knowing full well that they were going
to eat
God knew ahead of time they were going
to eat so for him not to have given them
a route and a way to remove the sin from
themselves would have been unfair unjust
unjust so he gave them that knowledge
how to repent if you sin so when they
realize that they had sinned they
repented and so the sin was removed from
them that's why the process of
repentance is in the hands of each and
every individuals not a special priest
caste class that they're the ones who do
forgiveness you have to go and sit in a
booth and make confess your sins and
then they the priest comes out and says
your sins are forgiven that's not the
way you know it doesn't work that way
how are your sins are forgiven when some
of these
priests are committing more sins and the
people are confessing their sins yeah
you know this human being so forgiveness
belongs only to God that's the essence
of religion and that God will accept
that forgiveness from whomsoever turns
to him sincerely with a repentant heart
God will forgive them no matter how
great the sin is he's the most merciful
the most loving all we got to do is turn
to him alone exactly
simple that's the way the religion of
God should be it should be a simple
rational logical religion it shouldn't
have you know as you said mental
gymnastics as a pillar for you to be a
follower you've got to be a mental
gymnast you know how to make 3 1 and 1/3
no we just deal with one one that's it a
few more points before we come to an end
so much to talk about so little time
tell us now is the same concept that
happened with Adam I'm interested to
know is that what was beautified or
however he went off and slipped
today many of the things that were
supposed to stay away from the
fornication the adultery the alcohol and
the drugs it seems like that is just
beautified today well exactly a trick of
the that's one of the methodologies of
Satan and in the Koran addresses that
specifically he's saying that you know
Satan and actually when Satan makes that
open statement recorded in the Quran
that I will beautify for them ah you
know that's what I'm yeah yeah I will
beautify for them corruption cause that
they would accept it and that's exactly
what he did with the tree he came to
Adam and he told them that this tree is
the tree of life of eternal life so
beautiful I mean it before that Adam
wasn't thinking about eternal life in a
short life in such a way
eternal life yeah I need someone who
doesn't want to be eternal I need a
piece of that yeah so
he made it seem is that of all the
treason in the the whole of the garden
this is the one tree he had to eat from
yeah they began that is not exactly
what's happening now the media makes the
corruption seem like these things our
life is incomplete if we have not
experienced and tasted this thing our
life is it life and our life is just not
fulfilled unless we get to this thing
and these things that we are chasing
after which have been beautified for
answer corruption things which are
harmful to us as individuals harm to our
societies without a shadow of a doubt
has the truth always from the beginning
been opposed because you'll see a stigma
attached to this truth what we claim is
from the creator of the heavens in the
earth as it always been the way during
Moses time Jesus a time all the prophets
has there been opposing fourth forced to
try to lure people away from the correct
way absolutely it began with Adam and
Satan and will not end until the end of
this world and all that is living in it
dies and is resurrected The Satanic
forces will always be there throughout
this life as long as this world is
functioning it will be there it has been
from the very beginning did you remain
there till the end and this is a part of
the challenge and the test will we
submit our wealth to God or will we
submit our wills to Satan and his forces
plays on our desires plays on our needs
you know turns them into things which
are alluring to us but in fact harmful
to us so this process is a never-ending
process we just have to be conscious of
it we have to open up and wake up to
know what's really happening we have
only two minutes for those there might
have been a Muslim one who is
consciously submitted to the crater now
he has a non-muslim sitting next to him
and you know what now what you're saying
is life
logical rational and makes sense and now
all that person has to do it's already
naturally in them help give that
encouragement for the person that's read
about Islam he knows is the truth but
you know what the devil comes up and
says you know what you're gonna forsake
the religion of your forefathers and all
the other doubts that start creeping
them how could we encourage them to do
the right thing and what are the
benefits of doing the right thing
submitting to God well the benefits are
the eternal life that we are all seeking
eternal life in a beautiful and a good
and a pure sense one in a state where we
are at peace with God God pleased with
us and us with him I mean what better
state can we be in that is paradise so
that reward and that goal that we should
all have can only be achieved through
submitting ourselves to the will of God
known as Islam that is the bottom line
and without it no matter what we
accumulate on this world it will be
ultimately of no benefit
it won't last and we can't take it with
us
none of it it all stays behind yeah
others benefit Michael Jackson died
Bruce Lee died will die too
exactly pharaohs died you're still
looking at their bodies and their wealth
didn't benefit them at all you have an
Islamic works you have a website where
people can go and seek knowledge and
learn can you please tell the people
about this wonderful site before we come
to an end well we have a site known as
Islamic online University dot-com spread
it all out
Islamic online University dot-com there
there are free courses and most of them
are by me but there are others under
scholars whose work is up there and
we're adding more and more material you
can go there and freely access basic
information about this law
in a course and organized and animun
and we could say educationally sound
structured system you know because
oftentimes people try to learn you're
learning reading this book that book the
other book here there and all over the
place
and when in the end after one year two
years three years you look at what
knowledge you having it just doesn't
seem to come together you know because
it's scattered whereas what we need is a
structured program of learning and
that's what the Islamic online
university the IOU you know provides and
inshallah we're working on upgrading
that to be a level courses at either
minimum expense or completely free I
like to thank you may God Almighty Allah
the creator of the heavens and earth
were reward you for being with us it's
always a pleasure I'm doing that it's my
pleasure to be with you and hope to see
you many more times in the future yes
thank you thank you and thank you very
much for tuning into the Deen show we're
here every week to help you understand
the way of life of all the messengers
that's that way that way of submitting
yourself not to a man not to a woman but
the one who created man and woman the
creator of the heavens and earth the one
Jesus prayed to the one Moses prayed to
the one all the messengers of God
submitted themselves to and the last and
final messenger sent to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him if
you want to accept this way if you want
to do it now if you want to learn more
call the number on the screen 1 800 662
Islam come back here every week to the
Deen show we'll see you next time God
willing I'll sit on alaikum peace to you
the DVDs for Dawa as allah has said in
the quran in surah now 16 125 will do
alasa be a little bigger bill hikmah to
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
Allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world Islam
submission to the one God come and see
what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best to give
up for shipping guy this one I would
never give up spreading this message
okay you take that necessary step you
don't know if you're gonna live till
tomorrow so you got to find that urgency
to do the right thing right now if you
say that you do not believe in Jesus you
have stepped outside of the Sun you
cannot be a muslim and attended our
faith to eat scum eating everybody
sleeping i arise and ask a lot of
thinking me Omar you see all our you
know all the things I do I turn to you
to forgive my sin tomorrow I'm using for
slave you don't my love alone I'm the
one runs away all the guide me